daddies
Michael Douglas and Catherine Zeta
Jones's daughter Charis makes her can
debut we just have a lot of fun she's a
good girl the 20 year old joined her
parents at the film festival's opening
ceremony looking glamorous in an Ely SOB
lace gown her mama rocking the same
designer opting for a red dress and Cake
the ladies there to support their guy
Michael the event's honorary Palm Door
recipient to celebrate his career we
just have fun together I know we love
sports we like art we like
traveling we like a lot of things
missing from the can action the couple's
22 year old son Dylan are you officially
taller than your mother I think so yeah
I think the word is out you've heard it
here first Dylan supported his mom at
the premiere of Wednesday in November
would you like to share a night like
this with your son oh it's just
wonderful you know um I mean we're very
very close family you know so um it's
you know he he he gets this world
because he's being brought up in it but
he was never in like this environment
growing up you know he understands the
business the actors having actual actors
you know being his parents and the Apple
isn't falling far from the tree Dylan's
got the acting bug too I mean I'm kind
of was brought up in it so it's just
business as usual I never take this for
granted you know I get up and I work and
I act and I love it I would do it for
nothing of course you know my sons
we love acting and and the craft but
this is always exciting as for Karis
she's an aspiring singer who goes by her
initials see ZD
[Music]
[Applause]
she loves to act and sing and write
songs I think to just stick to yourself
um you know who you are better than
anyone knows you and you know like your
true values and stick to that and have
fun with that attitude we can totally
see The Zeta Douglas kids being just as
successful as their parents
[Music]